[Applause]
hi jerome i'm so happy to be here i'm
i'm such a huge fan so this is quite
quite quite an exciting morning
you were the front woman of a beloved
franchise
how do you feel about leaving laura jean
now what do you feel about this final
film i just watched it i love it so much
sorry to bury the lead you go
you know this
story has been a huge part of my life
and it's changed my life i
have played large now for three movies
and
i very much grew up with her and so it
kind of feels like saying goodbye to
a part of yourself which is which is odd
but i'm not saying goodbye to my friends
which is good um but yes it's gonna be a
lot i
i haven't quite fully processed yet i
must say
um
how do you feel about how this closes
out because i think there's some really
powerful life lessons in this third
installment you know i feel very very
good um
for the third movie i really wanted to
show that she
could step out into the world and make
the choices for herself um
that she believes is best for her
regardless of you know maybe it might
not be the popular opinion um in her
relationships but ultimately you want to
see a young woman
kind of come into her own and step out
into this crazy world i just think it's
a great way to go out of something that
people have lived with for years as well
and end it on this life lesson i feel is
very important i'm so excited for people
to see it man is it satisfying now
choosing yourself comes first but
choosing love also and i know your
boyfriend anthony you guys have been
together five years now
yes we've been together for five years
um he is
my everything he
i honestly don't know what i would do
without him he's always been my rock so
five years strong baby
i am telling you your relationship is so
authentic and beautiful and can i just
quickly run through a quick dating
advice tips that you have that i think
are so
great
yes
okay
dates look a little different do you
have any fun tips for date nights at
home um
so i would say
obviously
it's so important to just turn off your
phone and spend time together we might
be in the same room but we're on the
zooms we're on the calls all these
different things so to turn off kind of
the noise and just sit with each other
and talk okay this sounds silly but we
have this thing it's called literal it's
literally called talk time
and it's my favorite time because it's
like
uninterrupted talking time
um so have some talk time for yourself
i love it and then uh
dress up even if you're staying home i
think that the majority the majority of
the meals that we share together are in
sweatpants but
um if you want to make it special
obviously dressing up makes it kind of
feel a little yes like your beautiful
beautiful shirt
thank you it's i think that's such good
advice and then there was also take a
little drive
yeah and take a little drive um and
listen to music like we will get take
out and sit in the car and eat it um and
listen to music or watch something um
like watch a movie in the car that's
really nice because it's a little bit of
a change of scenery so there's a couple
ideas in there i love the ideas i think
they're great um incentivizations and i
started driving around with my girls
when the pandemic started because it was
just the three of us and we had nothing
to do and nowhere to go so i would play
albums and drive around with them now
lana before you go
i thought we would take the opportunity
this galentine's day to highlight a gal
owned business called happy box
happy box is an online curated build a
box store and it all started with
someone sending her sister a thoughtful
package to lift her spirits up after a
breakup and we thought we'd box up some
happiness for our vffs and uh send a
little valentine's their way there's
little candles and wine glasses ooh a
gold wine opener um oh and compartes
chocolate oh you cannot go wrong with
compartes so all the vffs you're going
to get 100 gift cards to
happyboxford.com so you can build a
little valentine's day box
i'm so happy for your success and it
makes so much sense because you are
smart beautiful
and we're all
loving watching you do your thing thank
you
thank you for having me um and i hope
you have a beautiful valentine's day i
will and thank you for putting wonderful
things for us to watch out in the world
we really need them right now we always
need them but now in particular to all
the boys always and forever is streaming
now on netflix
[Music]